Charles Darwin the mild-mannered son of
a physician was once described as the
most dangerous man in England in fact
many people considered him to be the
agents of the devil himself come to sow
seeds of corruption among the faithful
his ideas struck like a storm at the
very foundation of society turning
conventional religious thought on its
head yes just a few years earlier he had
his sights set on becoming a priest and
devoting his life to God
in this week's biographic Swee
investigates the life and the ideas of
Charles Darwin
[Music]
Charles Robert Darwin was born in
Shrewsbury England on February the 12th
1809 his father Robert was a doctor and
his mother Susannah was the daughter of
the famous potteries owner Josiah
Wedgwood Charles's grandfather was
Erasmus Darwin well known in his time as
a scientist with unusual ideas he wrote
on a range of subjects including travel
by air or exploring by submarine and
evolution despite his learned father and
eminent grandfather Charles's early
years were not outstanding the attended
Shrewsbury School where the main lessons
were in the classics such as Latin his
school masters and his father considered
him to be a boy of very ordinary
intelligence despite his apparent lack
of promise Charles showed a great
interest in learning but rather than
studying Greek and Latin like most of
the students of the time he was taken
with the English poetry of William
Wordsworth and Lord Byron when Charles
was a teenager science began to
captivate him so much so in fact that he
had his brother Erasmus build a
chemistry lab in a garden shed in 1825
Charles attended Edinburgh medical
school in Scotland but he was not a good
medical student
he found the lectures dull Mann's had to
leave the operating theatre because he
could not stand the horrors of surgery
one thing he did enjoy though was the
study of taxidermy which he learned from
a former African slave named John
Edmondson
during his second year in Scotland
Darwin joined the plinian society a club
for naturalists he was taken with their
intellectual debates which exposed him
to ideas of how man was created not by
gods but by gradual changes in form over
time these ideas had been espoused by
Charles's own grandfather Erasmus Darwin
while at the University Darwin met a
zoologist named Robert grant and the two
became close friends grant has been
credited with being the first person to
interest Darwin in the theory of
evolution at this time Charles began
collecting fossils sent learning more
about animal life to the great
disappointment of his father Charles
quit Medical School in 1827 he joined
his uncle Josiah Wedgwood the second for
a trip to Paris as he vacations his
father still fretting over his son
dropping out of medical school made
plans for Charles to study for the
clergy enrolling him at Christ's College
at Cambridge University despite the
evolutionary ideas that have been
filling his mind's during his time at
Edinburgh Charles still held to a belief
in creation later Eros I did not then in
the least doubt the strict and literal
truth of every word in the Bible during
the summer before his studies began
Charles fell in love with a girl by the
name of fanny Owen the sister of one of
his friends they spent long hours
talking riding horses and playing cards
Darwin's theological studies at
Cambridge began towards the end of 1827
but rather than getting immersed in the
Bible he developed a fondness for
collecting beetles he attended lectures
on botany given by the Reverend John
Stephens henslowe Darwin saw this as a
possible career path and he pursued his
studies with enthusiasm by 1829 it
became clear that Darwin had no interest
in joining the clergy he spent that
spring break with the Reverend Frederic
hope and noted entomologist his
obsession with the study of beetles saw
no time for his budding romance with
Fanny and they broke up that following
spring
despite his general lack of interest in
his clerical studies Darwin passed his
finals exam in January 1831 placing
tenth in his class finished with school
he was all set to become a countryside
clergy or the eighth one with a deep
scientific
interests but Reverend Hensley who had
become something of a mentor to Charles
suggested that he should see some of the
world before he settled down to his
posting Darwin decided to take a trip to
the Canary Islands off the coast of
Spain he planned to go with his friends
Marmaduke Ramsey they intended to study
the geological formations on the islands
but before they could set sail
Ramsey died suddenly Darwin was stricken
with grief and could not travel to the
islands a few weeks later though he
received a letter from Reverend Henslow
informing him that there was an opening
on a ship that may interest him the HMS
Beagle which was bound for South America
the Beagle was being prepared as one of
several ships scheduled to map South
America Robert Fitzroy the captain of
the Beagle recognized that the long
voyage would require for a variety of
men to be on board for companionship he
was keen to have a scholar gentleman who
could help describe the areas that were
being charted as well as to relieve the
tedium between ports of cool when the
opening presented itself
Darwin was keen to fill spot however his
father Robert refused to give his adult
son permission to embark on the voyage
Robert continued to believe that
Charles's interest in science was merely
a passing fad and that the young man
remained adrift it was left to Charles's
uncle Josiah to step in and persuade his
brother to give permission for his son
to join the expedition Charles then
hastened to London to meet with Captain
Fitzroy in the hope that the offer was
still available he was in luck with
plans for a September departure
gradually moved back the ship finally
set sail on Tuesday December 27th
1831 Darwin found himself in a small
cabin that was nine feet by 11 feet long
and only five feet high part of his
cabin was taken off by one of the masts
rising through it from the start he was
seasick a condition that remained over
the next five years On January the 16th
1832 the Beagle stopped at Cape Verde
off the western coast of Africa here
Darwin found a band of fossil shells 45
feet above sea level how he wondered
could the fossils rise so high after 23
days the crew set out for Brazil
arriving in the port city of Salvador at
the end of February 1832
throughout the spring the Beagle
travelled along the Brazilian coast
stopping in many ports at each stop
Darwin took long hikes collecting many
specimens he collected a huge number of
specimens which he carefully catalogued
and protected on board Fitzroy and the
crew they considered his work worthless
and his growing collection a load of
junk but to Charles they were precious
scientific discoveries every few months
he arranged for a shipment to be sent
back to Reverend Henslow in Cambridge
for safekeeping
from Brazil the Beagle sailed to
Patagonia a large region of South
America that is now Argentina there
Darwin collected fossils bits of bone
and feathers that he had never before
encountered he struggled to accurately
record their features in the hopes that
more experienced natural ists could
later help to identify them from
Patagonia the Beagle went further to
Tierra del Fuego it was here that Darwin
encountered native people who still
dwelled in the jungle and were
considered to be its savages by the
Europeans by March of 1833 the crew of
the Beagle began mapping the Falkland
Islands which the British had claimed
from Argentina just months earlier
fascinated by the burdened animal
fossils found there Darwin spent his
time comparing the specimens with
everything he had collected to date the
work that Darwin was immersed in was
becoming so exhaustive that he
recognized the need to take on a servant
he wrote home to his father asking for
the money to hire someone
when permission came back he asked the
ship's odd job man Sims Covington to
take on the role meanwhile the letters
that Charles had been sending back to
Reverend henslowe were being read aloud
to the philosophical Society of
Cambridge this earns Darwin an early
reputation as an excellent naturalist
and observer on Darwin's 25th birthday
captain Fitzroy named the highest
mountain in the Tierra del Fuego region
mount Darwin in Charles's honor by 1834
the ship had sailed round Cape Horn at
the southern tip of South America and
crossed from the Atlantic to the Pacific
Ocean during the summer Darwin became
quite ill he was deemed too sick to
continue the voyage and spent four
frustrating months in Tierra del Fuego
recovering historians believe that he
had chaga disease which is a form of
sleeping sickness Darwin returned to the
Beagle in November of 1834 the ship
rounded Cape Horn and sailed up South
America's west coast On February the
20th 1835 a great earthquake
shook the region entering the port of
concepción chile darwin saw the
appalling damage he also noted that the
rocks around the harbor had been lifted
almost a metre by the earth's movements
shellfish and seaweeds which were
normally near the water were now high
and dry
so could such catastrophic changes in
the surroundings be linked to changes in
parts and animals is what he wondered
the beagle now left South America and
set sail across the Pacific Ocean almost
a thousand kilometres from the mainland
it angered as a group of about 13 small
rocky islands on the equator these were
of course the Galapagos Islands Darwin
was immediately struck by the strange
nature of the birds reptiles and others
that he found there
they seemed unique to these islands yet
they had many similarities to species
found on the South American mainland
stranger still each island had its own
kind of animal one example was the giant
tortoises weighing more than 200
kilograms which the ship's crew rode
around like horses the local people
could tell which Island - tortoise came
from by the shape of its shell
Darwin was especially intrigued by one
group of birds the finches they were
mostly small and drab brown in color but
each species had a slightly different
size and shape of beak allowing it to
tackle a certain kind of food Darwin
noted in his notebook one might really
fancy that from an original poor city of
birds in the archipelago one species had
been taken and modified for different
ends the idea of evolution and it was
beginning to take root the Beagle sailed
on across the Pacific to Tahiti where
Darwin fell in love with the misty Peaks
tropical plants colorful animals and the
simple natural lifestyle of the local
people the journey continued on towards
New Zealand and then Australia he was
shocked at the terrible living
conditions of the local people in their
own lands they were ruled over and made
slaves by Europeans Attalus this seemed
to support his observations from the
animal world that the stronger always
took over from the weaker
the Beagle returned to Falmouth England
on the 2nd of October 1836 they had been
away for five years Darwin spent the
next few years organizing and
cataloguing his vast collection of
plants animals rocks and fossils by the
summer of 1838 Darwin felt bold enough
to share his radical ideas with his
father who took them in his stride for
the last several months Charles had
struck up a close relationship with his
cousin Emma Wedgwood however when he
brought up the subject of marrying Emma
his father warns that she came from a
very strict family Emma would never
consider Darwin's theories as anything
but heresy deeply in love though Darwin
ignored his father's advice to curtail
the romance he mentions some of his
notions regarding religion in nature to
Emma who was surprisingly understanding
Darwin juggled numerous tasks from
writing books to studying more fossils
to watching Apes and orangutangs at the
London Zoo as he worked he also
continued his relationship with Emma he
proposed to her on November the 11th
1838 the proposal was well received by
both sides of family arrangements were
made for Darwin to receive a handsome
annual sum of money from his father this
would allow the couple to live
comfortably while Darwin continued
retaining Covington's services since
research on his theory of evolution was
still incomplete Charles and Emma were
married on January the 29th 1839 the
couple settled into a home in London
which was already filled with scientific
material shortly thereafter Cummington
left Darwin's employment to make his own
fortune he was replaced by a man named
Joseph Parsloe during the spring of 1839
Darwin carried out research on
crossbreeding he asked various experts
including farmers questions about
healthy crossbred their animals he
filled page after page with his
correspondences in May V multi-volume
collection he wrote with Captain Fitzroy
narrative of these surveying voyages of
the HMS Beagle was finally released to
the public this celebration of the
beagles voyage it became a best-seller
Charles was now a respected scientist
and author and a member of the Royal
Society
[Music]
during the 1840s and 1850s Darwin
continued his research and writing in
1842 he wrote a geology book entitled
the structure and distribution of coral
reefs with two more geology books
following in the next few years as time
went on though his health began to fail
he could only do a few hours of work
each day there's all this it was never
identified but it could have been the
after-effects of his tropical sickness
while on his five-year voyage the
spider's illness he continued his
research into the idea of evolution he
was becoming more and more convinced
that species were not fixed and
immutable he had written a short version
of his ideas in 1842 but decided to
collect every scrap of information he
could and write a lengthy book with
masses of evidence for his theory for
many years
Darwin was reluctant to publish his
ideas on evolution by natural selection
it's meant that animals and plants
evolved naturally he now believed that
God had not created them however most
people at the time including many
scientists still believed in the truth
of the Bible he knew that speaking out
against the accepted teachings of the
Bible was certain to offend and caused a
storm of protest
Darwyn may have never finished his work
on evolution but for a letter which
arrived at his home in Kent in June 1885
from Malaysia it was from another
English naturalist Alfred Wallace
Wallace knew that Darwin was interested
in evolution so with his letter he sent
his summary of the theory
Darwin was amazed all of the work he had
so patiently done over the last 20 years
was neatly described by Wallace at a
scientific meeting at the naen Society
in London the works of both Wallace and
Darwin were read out in July of 1858
after that Wallace agreed that Darwin
who had gathered far more evidence to
support their joint theory should carry
on with the idea while he stood aside
Darwin did so quickly finishing his
great book it was published on the 24th
of November 1859 and it was called the
Origin of Species the publisher of
Darwin's book John Murray
reddit's before printing it and realised
a great outcry would follow as a result
he only printed 1,250 copies these sold
out almost at once and a second edition
was quickly produced people they were
indeed outraged Darwin was denying the
truth that was in the Bible
scientists lined up to have their say
with many criticising Darwin one
clergyman called the quiet mild-mannered
Darwin the most dangerous man in England
but others quickly recognized the good
science in Darwin's ideas and the vast
amount of evidence which supported them
the biologist Thomas Huxley spoke of him
in England while professor of botany at
Harvard University ASA gray was his
great supporter in North America Darwin
himself stayed in Kemps and took little
part in the arguments so now the
question arises well what did Darwin
actually postulate in his famous book
well the Origin of Species by means of
natural selection or the preservation of
favoured races in the struggle for life
is a long but very readable book it
begins by looking at variation under
domestication including pigeons horses
and garden flowers then it covers
variation in nature and the problems of
identifying species it shows how the
offspring of parents are all similar but
slightly different these slight
differences might give an individual a
better chance of succeeding and staying
alive later chapters deal with animal
instincts fossils and
the geographical manner of animals and
plants from mice to elephants yet he
never explains the origin of any one
species as I mentioned the Origin of
Species shocked and angered many people
including Darwin's own family to accept
the theory of evolution meant accepting
that the accounts in the Bible of
creation of animal and plant species
could not be true many scientists they
simply struggled to believe in both
gradually however the theory of
evolution by natural selection gained
ground and most scientists came to
believe that Darwin was right Darwin he
did not retire after the Origin of
Species was published he kept up his
studies and researchers and carried on
with his experiments and nature
observations in 1871 he published the
scent of man and selection in relation
to sex in this work he concluded that
humans are not the result of special
creation but that they have evolved
along with other animals their ancestors
could indeed be traced back far into
prehistory in the 1870s Darwin's health
improved and in 1877 he was awarded a
special degree by Cambridge University
he continued to write books about insect
eating plants how plants grow and move
and how they encouraged decay and
enriched the soil with dissent a huge
success as well Darwin divided his time
between revising the two works in April
of 1874 he completed work on descents
second edition this was the last time he
wrote about evolution between projects
and illnesses Darwin continued to refine
his work a decade after its first
publication the fifth edition of Origin
was released the sixth edition published
in 1871 used the word evolution for the
first time after a mild heart attack in
December of 1881 Charles Darwin died
several months later peacefully a down
house his home of nearly 50 years he was
73 years old by this time the storm of
protest over the Origin of Species had
died away and Darwin had become a
national figure and one of the
best-known scientific names of all time
he was laid to rest at Westminster Abbey
London next to the great Isaac Newton
the funeral was attended by dozens of
politicians inventors explorers
scientists and artists along with
members of the scientific communities of
many countries so I really hope you
enjoyed that episode of biographic if
you did there's a couple of things you
could do right now
one is hit that like button below also
if you want more stuff like this we put
out brand new videos every Monday and
every Thursday so hit that subscribe
button below and subscribe button
doesn't do what it used to on YouTube if
you actually want to get a notification
about these videos please do hit that
Bell button next do the subscribe button
and that'll send you a notification
every time every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video also if you
want to watch something else right now
stuff from the archive over there on the
right and as always thank you for
watching